bonjour et bienvenue sur diagonale tv
championnat du monde féminin 2016 dont
kiffan ou face à maria musi tchouk alors
donc à chinoises mènent d'un point la
victoire dans la deuxième partie elle
avait les blancs mariam ou zid choucas
fait une belle partie dans la troisième
elle a essayé de tenter une autre
ouverture et finalement à jouer une
partie assez dynamique mais n'a pas
réussi à poser de véritables problèmes à
son adversaire
donc ici ils se retrouvent de nouveau
avec les noirs avec le challenge qui est
que si elle perd encore cette partie ça
va être
extrêmement délicat pour ce championnat
du monde qui n'a que dix partis c'est
déjà la quatrième on est presque à la
moitié bon qu'il s'agit pour elle de ne
surtout pas perdre
et pourquoi pas bon bien sûr on peut
toujours espérer gagner avec les noirs
et mais c'est bien sûr plus difficile
alors comment va jouer aussi kiffan
ou est ce qu'elle va répéter les coups
bas on va voir ça tout de suite donc
c'est quatrième partie du championnat du
monde c'est parti avec peu 4 voilà donc
elle varie pas un iphone mousser son
coût de 4 évident ya pas de raison de
varier à la gagner donc c'est à
l'adversaire de démontrer que il peut
tenir et elle rejoue la même chose aux 5
pour l'instant cavalier trois cavaliers
6 alors est-ce qu'on va droit avoir
droit de nouveau à une orgie lopes
est-ce qu'on va avoir une variation sur
une italienne est ce qu'on va avoir un
autre coup j'ai pas un peu n'importe
quoi non pour avouer qu'à laisser 3 on
doit pouvoir jouer ses trois on doit
pouvoir jouer des 4 alors que va faire
là la favorite au classement c'est la
favorite même si c'est pas la championne
en titre
elle était déjà championne bien sûr
avant c'est fou les symboles la foulée
celle choisie par guy fans fous b5
c'est larrouy lopez ça ne change pas à 6
donc même variante pour l'instant x 4
cavaliers m6 attaque le pion central ans
le 4 mai on le défend indirectement en
faisant le petit rorqual à petit rock et
en cas de prise et bien sûr on pourra
centraliser la tour c'est d'ailleurs ce
qui va se passer puisque elle joue la
même variante voilà elle ne rentre pas
maria musi tchouk dans la variante ici
que l'on aurait pu tenter mais sûre
c'est la grande dame de la rue lopes à
base de baies 5 fu b3 et est maintenant
et bien sans doute fawcett a suivi de
rock c'est la grande arène de la ruine
au ps mais elle rentre pas là dedans non
elle continue la même variante qui lui a
valu une défaite alors on va voir des
quatre coups logique
j'ouvre le jeu au maximum en cas de
prise et bien tout re 1 ce cavalier et
cloud et on comprend que ça va être
délicat de le tenir longtemps au centre
bessaih d'abord on tue le l'action du
fou fou mais trois des cinq des 5
on consolide la position du carioca
surtout on ne perd pas de temps
supplémentaire en prenant en d4 on a
déjà perdu un pion enfin un pion on n'a
pas perdu depuis on a perdu un temps
pour prendre le quatre faux pas en
perdre trop dans l'ouverture fonds
publics on avait noir on l'a déjà un
coup de retard au début si on les ajoute
les coups de retard ça va finir par
coûter cher
puis on prend 1,5 et faut aussi savoir
la fosse is normal le pion des cinq
étaient attaqués par le four b3 et par
la dame il fallait absolument défendre
ce pion à problèmes et c3 alors là c'est
une variation un parent par rapport à la
première j'ai vérifié
non monsieur je me réveille pas les cons
parker mais j'ai quand même vérifier ici
lifan avait joué les 20 premières
fouilles 3 et ensuite il ya eu fawcett
ce qui est pas donc tout à fait pareil
elle joue d'abord c3 voilà la mariée
muzitu joue quand même fou aux 7 c'est à
peu près le même coût et la cie fans
avaient joué le coup fougue 3 c'était la
même que la première partie et
l'ancienne qui change en premier ajout
c2 alors ça c'est un peu un peu curieux
dans la mesure où effectivement on peut
se dire belgique a regagné la première
pourquoi le répète pas les coûts
évidemment il faut s'attendre à ce que
mariam ou zouk et améliorer sa partie
entre temps elle a passé trois jours
d'ici depuis lass est parti pour en ne
faisant rien évidemment avec ses seconds
en serre son équipe de championnat du
monde mais sûre ils ont travaillé cette
position et afu g4 alors c'est la même
idée que dans la première mais la
position un peu différente on cloue ce
fameux kf3 et rappelez-vous dans la
première abel et blanc avait laissé
prendre à f3 il avait repris du pian
g et s'était retrouvé avec un des pions
doublé mais avec un forte une forte fort
dynamisme en fout g4 a remis dans le
problème ici posée par les noirs c'est
de dire je vais l'éliminer ce cavalier
puits d'où il ya le pion une scène
derrière qui est en prison alors h3
alors ça c'est ça c'est un coup
surprenant donc safwan alizés ce coup
parce qu'évidemment ici les noirs
auraient pu c'est parce qu'ils ont fait
mais on peut regarder quand même il
aurait pu prendre un f3 c'est le coup
logique si on prend en f3 l'idée c'est
qu'on va manger le pion 5 alors là sur
la pelouse en f3 on peut quand même
toujours reprendre du plongeon pourquoi
on fait ça mais sur ce cas sa structure
de pian priori mais rappelez vous il ya
2 il ya deux choses c'est que 1 on à la
paire de fou alors qu'en face y'a pas
y'a pas véritable attaque contre laurent
blanc parce que la bombe et on voit mal
comment les noirs ou en hockey du grand
côté ici ce serait extrêmement
surprenant puisque les blancs - là c'est
très vite une attaque avec abbas 2 à 4
et tout va s'ouvrir et c'est le noir qui
vont subir une attaque et ils sont pas
prévu d'ouvrir le jeu de ce côté là ces
trois pions ils ont été prévus pour
faire le petit rock aussi ont fait le
petit rock petit rock bombay le roi est
certes un peu en l'air mais bon il n'y a
pas de gros dangers quoi donc il ya des
pions double en compensation et puis
surtout après on va jouer sans doute f4
et on aura un beau duo de plomb de deux
pions de plomb on pourra avoir
éventuellement un beau duo 2
deux pions donc s 4,5 au centre c'est
quand même un pion qui certes doublé
mais qui est allé quand même vers le
centre voilà on peut aussi protéger
parfois f4 on l'a vu dans la partie donc
voilà c'est ça qui se serait passé sur
la prison nourrir repris sans doute du
pire on voit là avec un peu la même idée
que dans la première donc attention
elles tombent pas dans le piège maria
puisqu'elle fait ici force 5 5l dix
bombes et c'est bon j'ai compris les
pulls ou blessés ça peut être bon mais
en l'occurence j'ai pas envie de donner
affaire de fous donc je recule g4 alors
ça c'est responsable parce qu'on a déjà
ok on avance les pions devant le roi là
on peut donner du grain à moudre noire
qui pourrait ensuite jouer h57 alors que
là le coude et noircit les 6 mai sur est
là bien sûr h5 pour ouvrir bon mais un
sur h5
on pourrait fermer par gsm quoique il ya
quand même pas mal de pièces khattak
ou alors on laisse ouvrir mais
finalement c'est pas très dangereux dans
la mesure où bombay et la toho tout seul
attaquer ici on va jouer roi g2 est
peut-être on va contester la colonne h
et on va revenir on va venir avec la
tourache 1 et après les échanges c'est
pas clair que finalement ce soit pas
davantage des blancs cette ouverture de
ligne
donc on a moyennement peur de cette
possibilité mais il faut quand même y
réfléchir bien sûr car les d4 a alors ça
piège
imaginons que les noirs ici prennent en
cinq ans calais des cats a été jouée
pour libérer ce point est ce justement
d'accord regardez maintenant f4 le cas
les bouches
on n'a pas trop le choix je prends mon
livre
par exemple en session 17 déjà en cédant
17 c'est pas terrible puisqu'il ya
cavaliers ccisc attaque la dame est fou
mais tout simplement il ya aussi f5
voilà et regarder le foot ça s'appelle
ça un petit peu l'arche de noé on
appelle ça parce que on amène tous les
animaux je ne sais pas enfin tout cas le
fouet la bête est complètement prise 1
voilà elle ne peut pas y a pas de casque
wall a été embarqué dans un piège voilà
donc bon on peut pas prendre le plus de
trop dangereux donc ici après calais des
quatre c'est cavaliers prend des 4 le
cavaly été attaqué bon qu'est ce que ce
qu'on aurait pu jouer d'autres un autre
c'est un peu délicat on peut envisager
d'amd cette dame 17 à la fois je perds
mais j'envisage quand même le grand
roque avis pourquoi pas pour lancer une
attaque ça peut avoir du sens c'est
possible il aurait pu aussi tenté ça
mais bon c'est une variante comme une
autre elle a choisi de prendre c'est
prendre et la paume voilà ça y est c'est
l'heure alors h5 au bon moment parce que
les blancs ne peuvent pas vraiment
éviter la halle à l'ouverture ici ou
alors il faudrait d'abord prendre avec
le fou en cas pourquoi parce que si on
avance le pion pour éviter l'ouverture
on pousse gsm on est protégé que par le
fou et le cavalier reprendre ici attaque
campion f3 en plus on peut aussi prendre
mais donc c'est pas bon on peut pas
empêcher l'ouverture
donc la f3 f3 et là c'est dangereux la
f3 alors ça paraît un coût nécessaire
pour essayer d'enlever cette ce bestiau
l'un qui est quand même pénible et il
est au centre ici il est protégé par un
fou alors est ce qu'on aurait pu
envisager autre chose on aurait pu
envisager pour les blancs un coût plus
agressif kiev 4 avec la même idée
combien de voir c'est-à-dire f5 gagne le
fou ou quasi gagnent le fou il peut
encore venir h sets serrés
il recule mais là du coup il le fou est
mort ici en achète puisqu'il est dominé
par les pions et en plus la tour est
bouché voilà donc ce serait
une extinction des feux voilà une
extinction delà de l'action des pièces
des pièces noires il vient pour
poursuivre le développement cavaliers
c'est trop insistants mais bon un f4 et
forme voilà donc la sueur f4 bien les
noirs auraient sans doute eu des
problèmes lac
peut-être qu'il serait obligé de jouer
un coup comme f5 pour donner de l'air
aux fous la case f700 boucher l'action
de la tour et on n'a pas peur d'aucune
des prises en cinq ou en effet sisp en
passant pour reprendre du fou la prison
insein reprendre du fou pile de fouilles
très bien ils attaquèrent 3 bon bref
donc f4 et était peut-être fort rude
quoi donc elle fait un coup là ici ou
lifan un peu tendancieux f3 pourquoi je
dis ça mais parce qu'elle bien sûr
s'attaque lecavalier mais regardez la
suite cavale et g3 c'est ce que je veux
rien ausy toute attaque la tour alors
coup qui paraît quand même dangereux à
double tranchant parce que j'attaque la
tow qui va devoir bouger mon très bien
j'ai gagné un temps je vais pouvoir
prendre ici et l'ouvrir mais le cavalier
attention il est un peu isolé ceci dit
une simple réflexion rapide nous permet
de constater que un coup comme fou h4
possible ou alors je sors le fou d'une
façon ou d'une autre c'est la dame qui
marche 4 ce cavalier protégé et il ya
une attaque ici sur le colonel alors il
faut faire attention dans ce type de
manoeuvre qui paraît bonne comme ça et
mais bon un championnat du monde c'est
pas parce que ça paraît bon que c'est
bon il faut faut être sûr que c'est bon
parce que si ça rate l'attaquent
lecavalier et risquent d'être paumé
peuple il hérisse est perdu à long terme
parce qu'il n'a pas de casse de sortie h
5 f 5e cas tout ça est pris par les
pions les pions contrôler ces cases donc
à long terme il a il sera perdu donc il
faut faire attention à ce genre de coups
mais c'est dangereux clairement et donc
elle a dû calculer tout ça donc tout
reste deux mille fans ici
mais sort la tour mais plutôt plat m 1
mm f2 pour protéger un petit peu cette
deuxième rangée là on sait jamais ce qui
peut se passer on peut éventuellement on
pourra éventuellement venir en h2 pour
contrer l'action de la tour c au nord de
jouer mais évidemment on m'ouvre voilà
on ouvre le jeu et voient là une
magnifique passe d'aaron regardez c'est
superbe
alors ici juste pour dire les noirs ici
au lieu d'ouvrir aurait pu échanger
d'abord le fou demande d'ailleurs
pourquoi n'ont pas fait faux prend ces
deux donc sans doute dame prend ces deux
et ensuite simplement prendre angers 4
prises prise et puis tout rage 2 il ya
ya une contre attaque sur la tour on
peut regarder cette variante
il faut absolument la regarder parce que
la partie est beaucoup plus délicate
faux prince et 2 donc je reprends de la
dame pourquoi de la dame pour rajouter
regarder de la rive de la protection sur
la deuxième rangée
ça fait peur quand même alain cavalier
quand même qu'ils contrôlent des casses
prix du roi mais comme j'ai dit c'est
double tranchant il peut être beau mais
aussi à long terme donc ici après la
prise les noirs pourrait alors peut-être
pas on pourrait prendre tout de suite
mais si on prend
puis on prend pions prend on n'a pas
peur de tours h un échec puisque on joue
et on peut regarder aller on prend garde
on va regarder h proche de 4 oui et puis
en plus il ya aussi on peut aussi jouer
dam des six échecs et on peut pas
défendre de la dame puisque la tour
serait perdue pour déjouer roi et fuite
et après on pourrait reprendre c'est
possible aussi
c'est délicat c'est délicat donc ils
prennent pas les noirs tout de suite ils
se pressent pas non ça c'est bien joué
de la part de maremne gichuki joue un
coût beaucoup plus subtil et beaucoup
plus juste c'est bien entendu le coup
ici bon jour et elle jouer parce que
c'est pas la partie elle jouerait le
coût d'un des sept dames 17 puisque dan
17 mai j'enlève cette possibilité de
dames 6 échecs faut faire attention
je me prépare pourquoi pas le grand
regret j'ai plus peur que les blancs
attaque parce que c'est moi qui je vais
attaquer en premier ici je vais prendre
et je risque de doubler les tours avec
un matin là il va y avoir un accès sûr
et avec un cavalier proche du roi les
tours qui arrive yamaha tout il ya gagne
matériel il va y avoir des choses y
voyant des calculs des calculs et des
combinaisons et là bon mais c'est
délicat envoyé ici
bon ben ya quand même une pression moins
la prise ici risque venir en n'importe
quand peut être on peut boucher avec les
leurs mais si on bouche
le problème de bouche et c'est que ça
donne tout noir parce que le cavalier
peut sortir du coup avec 5 alors que là
le problème qu'il a ce qui peut pas
sortir ce qui le contrecoup de cette
attaque
on a un risque sur ce cavalier gsm jeu
même quand même c'est et puis pourra
venir en h4 à prendre fin de l'hiver
monstrueuse cavaliers subercazes ici
donc on touche on peut pas bouger donc
on est à la merci de l'ouverture angers
4 des noirs quand ils veulent
on peut préparer en fait on peut faire
le rôle de ren rock on peut peut-être
doubler les tours et après profit car on
peut faire un peu attendre longtemps
avant de prendre mais les blancs peuvent
aussi jouer fouet f4 attaque le cavalier
est là cette fois il faut réagir tout de
suite plus on sort une pièce ce qui
semble efficace et les leurres peuvent
protéger mais s'il protège par h4 il y
aura plus d'ouverture oui c'est toujours
à double tranchant ces histoires voilà
donc voilà ce qui aurait pu se passer
au lieu de quoi surtout rev 2 elle joue
peut-être le moins précis je sais pas si
c'est moins précis ou pas d'ailleurs
j'en sais rien elle joue h congé 4 je
prends les quatre salaires fort quand
même j'ouvre le jeu bon très bien vous
d'échangés mais le problème c'est que
les blancs ou l'intermédiaire fou prend
je prends angers 6 d'abord j'élimine se
fout ja faibli un tout petit peu le roi
noir ce qui peut être utile
et puis en cas de prise ici peut être un
coup comme dame ces deux menaces à la
fois dame pranger six échecs mais aussi
pourquoi pas d'âme ses six échecs on l'a
vu un petit peu je peux pas protégés de
la dame sinon je perds la tour à 8 avec
échec
et si je viens sur f7 et je suis devant
la tour là devant la tour blanche
et donc si je vais fc twente 8 je suis
devant la tour là je peux reprendre ici
en faisant échec
et là c'est les banques attaquées il ya
peut-être mat pour les blancs voyez que
tout ça est très compliqué donc il faut
prendre si d'intervenir mais bon elle a
calculé qu'en même qu'est ce qu'elle va
nous faire un joli comme tout reproche
trois pas mal ça paraît très fort
puisque aux menaces tour échec roi bouge
et la dame est perdu il faut faire
quelque chose le four est en prime
et on aimerait bien ce qu'on aimerait
bien se débarrasser de ce fou parce
qu'il faut il était pas là on viendrait
tout de suite en h4 et on voit très vite
que c'est quasi matt fiddes dame l adami
si la tour là le cavalier là on voit mal
on voit mal comment comment on peut
comment on peut s'en sortir
donc c'est chaud quoi mais là regardez
précis où des fans se trompent pas d'âme
c2a lors d'un de ces deux bombes et un
j'enlève la menace tour échec suivi de
tout reprend damian plus et j'ai un
petit oeil sur le fou ce qui fait qu en
cas de prise du fou et bien je peux
toujours avoir mon fameux échec
angers 6 on peut regarder
imaginons que les noirs prennent angers
6 alors je peux prendre angers 6 ou
alors je peux jouer aussi dame ces six
échecs alors il semblerait que le coup
wisdom pranger si c'est encore plus fort
lors dame c6 est fort aussi je peux pas
vraiment joué dans 17 ou alors si mais
il faut que je donne la tour alors
l'intérêt ici c'est que d'un projet qui
semble beaucoup plus fort pour la raison
que la dame va se trouver projet du roi
vous allez voir pourquoi d'un projet six
échecs ici si le roi viande 17 regarder
mais d'un projet quatre échecs
et puis je ramasse tout la tour le
cavalier tout quoi c'est l'horreur
et si le roi vient par exemple en est
bien cuite sinon c'est la seule autre
case n'y a pas trop le choix
là je peux prendre en f4 avec le pion
avec échec alors ceci dit je peux même
attendre un coup je suis pas pressé je
peux même jouer un coup qui semble
encore plus fort c'est qu'a laissé 3
pourquoi parce que ben je prends ici
quand je veux parce que le pion peut pas
bouger de toute façon l'intérêt de
calais ces trois c'est qu'en cas d'échec
en échec mais y'a rien qui tombe ni le
fonds ni rien du tout voilà donc la
je menace puis on prend g4 peut-être
même dame prend g4 la tour bouge et le
cavalier perdu ce genre de truc qu'au
fond les noirs ici c'est pas simple un
coût possible et de jouer bombay roi g8
pour éviter l'échec avec la prise du
pion et dans ce cas là on regarde
esquiver ce qui risque d'arriver c'est
d'un prend échec grand âge suite voyez
quand même là il est pas super à l'abri
parce que la colonne h et quand même
semaine verte ici enfin les couples est
ouverte avec la tour je crois qu'il
protège dents prend menace à la fois la
tour et le cavalier et un coup comme
dame c8 qui contrôle en transparence la
tour les possibles mais alors dans ce
cas là regardez tourache deux menaces de
prendre la tourache trois cas de prise
ici simplement on prend du roi et c'est
le cavalier cas pas de gaz elle n'est
pas de case des noirs prendre et ici on
reprend et ouf ça y est on sait trouver
une case pour le cac valeo ce on doit
pouvoir sortir ici mais on va encore
perdre des scènes d'où l'intérêt de ce
coup que les trois on va perdre des cinq
attaques le fou à taxer cette c'est
difficile et il ya plus une finale où
les blancs ont l'avantagé va ça va être
ça risque même être probablement gagnant
donc dame ces deux voiliers c'est chaud
donc là faut trouver un coût pour les
noirs un très joli coup trouvé par par
marianne aux heat shock apparemment ici
poussé 5
c'est l'idée que vous avez dit tout à
l'heure ça a l'air bon l'idée de pousser
et de pousser 5 c'est que 1 je retarde
je peux pas faire dams et six à orly
faut d'abord prendre le fou qui a pris
20 mai la regarder la dame elle a envie
de venir 1 h 4 est menacée mat
là ça fait peur ça fait très peur
imaginons que les blancs
c'est ce qu'ils vont faire ils vont
prendre le fou s'il avait joué autre
chose ce qu'on peut faire autre chose si
on avait enlevé ce fou par exemple est
ce qu'on aurait pu jouer sous des trois
maintenant ont regardé le fou là en plus
ils menacent de prendre des quatre avec
louage de la tour 1 c'est loris et
l'horaire donc il faut prendre ce fou
c'est ce qu'elle fait et la regarder
alors elle joue pas
damas quatre ici elle aurait pu essayer
ça mais ça marche pas nous ça marche
moins bien si ça marche aussi
apparemment parce qu'il y aurait dame
ces six échecs alors attention hein
tout est en effet nous ferions vieux
quand même moins fuite
alors si on vient aux 7 on va se prendre
dame prend c'est cet échec on vend en
fuite maintenant d'un prend à huit
échecs roi ici en 7
il ya plus de il ya plus d'échecs la de
la dame en tout cas alors le seul coup
qui resterait apparemment c'est de faire
bouger cinq échecs on sacrifie la
deuxième fois alors les c'est pourquoi
l'idée c'est d'enlever la dame de cette
colonne puisqu'il ya mat
donc on l'enlève de cette colonne et à
plume at il ya plus de mac a plus de
menace de maths en tout cas pas de me
dire et maintenant jelloun juste à temps
le temps de ramener la dame je menace de
prononcer cette avec 1
un perpétuel en quasi perpétuel il faut
dire que les noirs ont donné tellement
de pièces que je prends rendre voilà et
là bon c'est encore un délicat ça aurait
été possible à cette suite
voyez c'est compliqué on regarde et dit
maintenant l'idée de finale de marion
bouzigues choqué quand même assez joli
taux racheter un échec
moi j'ai deux et maintenant même pas
d'un match 4 mais regardez encore plus
jolie touche deux échecs à joly superbe
on peut pas prendre le cavalier temps on
peut on peut si les les blancs prennent
le cavalier la tension d'un match 4
échecs voilà c'est l'idée c'est l'idée
des êtres manoeuvre d'un match qu'à
trichet qui si le roi par exemple
enfin il n'a pas le choix il vient f4 et
la regarde et je peux prendre un f3 en
faisant un chèque de la dame et la balle
et les noirs les blancs vont cependant
près d'am prend tour avec échec et
ensuite on va continuer les échecs ça va
être l'horreur pas que c'est parce que
par exemple ça on va faire d'un problème
de échec 3 alors là on des trois là
c'est poussif 1 et on est tous ça par
exemple ici d'un bref un échec 3 ans et
3 je prends c1 c'est l'horreur le roi va
bouger et je peux même prendre b2 ou
prendre la dame prendre le fou à la fin
vous voyez que les noirs sont gagnants
il ya une qualité de plus et on peut
sans doute faire mieux dans cette
position encore donc c'est laurent voyez
que l'attaqué très très forte
alors imaginons maintenant que surtout
rage 2 échecs les blancs prennent la
tour ça c'est l'autre coup faut le
regarder à parer le coup logique
évidemment là tôt et emprisonnements
regarder le problème c'est ça pouf d'où
l'idée faussé scène vous avez vu on a
libéré l'action de la dame échec ou
valleroy bahia pas trop le choix si je
viens en j'ai un regard dont le tout
simplement regarder très joli match
assez matt protégé par le cavalier et la
tour eiffe de empêche le droit de sortir
très joli monde est assis ont bien en
j'ai deux c'est pareil c'est juste ça
retarde sa retard de deux coups
puisqu'il ya damas trois échecs
moi j'ai un essai le même là tu pars
d'un machin voilà donc voyez que c'est
quand même
c'est alors c'est une combinaison est
une combinaison de nul voila tac up
donc je reviens d'un processeur tour
échec
roger deux tours h deux ans j'ai tord h
un échec
et voilà et ça va pas plus loin la
partie est nulle part échec perpétuelle
les noirs ne peuvent pas espérer plus
ils ont quand même donné pas mal de
notes de matériel s'ils prennent le fou
ici c'est dangereux puisqu'ils vont se
prendre dame ces six échecs le web va
devoir bouger on va prendre g4 et le fou
à sortir en plus oui en plus le fou à
sortir il y aura un échec s'il revient
en cette si laura bush il va cependant
ce projet quatre échecs bref etc etc
ça risque d'être très très c'est un fait
ça sera très dangereux voilà c'est très
difficile d'aller chercher autre chose
ici mais c'est quand même un beau nul je
dirais une belle partie nulle de combat
sans doute une préparation parce que je
voulais ses coûts en partie c'est quand
même tendu on n'est pas très loin de
l'ouverture puisque on est au 21ème coup
donc il est possible que cette
combinaison nuls soit était étudiée est
bien étudiée avant par madame maria
bouzid ou alors c'est un bon point pour
maria puisqu'on avait peur qu'elle
s'écroule dans ce match après dé sa
défaite dès la deuxième partie mais non
elles elles tiennent bien il cette fois
avec les noirs donc elle a posé des
problèmes à huy fans qui doit donc
maintenant
et bien qu'il devra réfléchir à comment
aborder la suite avec les blancs et puis
bon mais maria maintenant aura les
blancs pour tenter de revenir au score
et donc il est bien parti dans ce match
maintenant pour poser des problèmes
malgré son point de moins voilà l'a
démontré qu'elle pouvait tenir et ça
c'est bon pour la suite des opérations
pour nous les spectateurs pour nous qui
suivons ce championnat du monde
le suspense est bien là et mariage musi
tout cas démontré qu'elle avait ses
chances
il faut éviter que bien sûr de refaire
un désastre comme dans la deuxième voilà
merci de m'avoir suivi donc pour cette
partie numéro 4 du championnat du monde
féminin 2016 sur diagonale tv rendez
vous sur le site aussi de diagonale tv
il ya un salon de discussion d'ailleurs
sur lequel vous pouvez vous pouvez venir
c'est un salon xmpp alors ça c'est pour
les informaticiens vous pouvez créer un
compte qu'on appelle un conte jaber vous
invite à le faire parce que c'est un
c'est un nouveau moyen de communication
libre c'est à dire qu'on ne dépend pas
d'un centre particulier et vous pouvez
alors discuter sur le salon directement
depuis le site web ou alors avec un
logiciel de chat
voilà sans passer par les par les
mastodontes du net qui qui centralise
tous là vous pourrez le faire de façon
décentralisée et vous connecter à vos
amis ou discuter sur le sol du banal tv
si vous avez envie etc
voilà donc à à bientôt un sur des
modèles tv merci de nous avoir suivis et
donc rendez vous pour la partie numéro 5
bientôt de ce championnat du monde de
au revoir